[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con el pasado 9
de abril el volcán del azufre en la isla
de san vicente y las granadinas entre
una serie de erupciones las primeras
desde 1979 la situación obligó a la
evacuación de unas 16.000 personas que
viven en zonas aledañas según la cruz
roja más de 290 mil personas de esta y
otras islas del caribe han estado
expuestas a los efectos de la erupción
esto sumado a la emergencia provocada
por el coronavirus para abordar este
tema saludamos desde san vicente y las
granadinas a ariel kerstens jefe de la
delegación es para el caribe de habla
inglesa y holandesa de la federación
internacional de la cruz roja
organización que está brindando ayuda
humanitaria a la población damnificada
bienvenido a fra 24 y cuéntenos cómo
ayudar a evacuar y brindar asistencia a
miles de personas al mismo tiempo tratar
de evitar aglomeraciones que puedan
contribuir a la propagación del cobi 19
bueno sí gracias por invitarme a su
programas bueno en realidad este es un
proceso que empieza muchas semanas y
meses antes incluso hoy dice día antes
de años antes que es todo el proceso de
preparación y preparación para estar
listos al momento de responder a un
desastre y después por supuesto
como ustedes probablemente sepa uno va
respondiendo a la desastre de acuerdo a
la capacidad que existe desde la
comunidad luego al distrito a la
provincia al país e internacionalmente
en este caso nosotros hemos activado el
sistema internacional de respuesta de la
cruz roja que complementa a las otras en
las otras fáciles y las otras capas y el
término de responder a un desastre como
es el volcán de las suscribir lo que
estamos haciendo ahora es trabajar
conjuntamente con las comunidades por
supuesto para entender cuáles son sus
necesidades y poder atenderlas lo más
rápidamente posible bueno por el país
también atraviesa un brote de dengue
esto está complicando aún más las
operaciones
sí por supuesto hay que tomar
precauciones extras no sólo por el tema
del brote de dengue que por el cual
estuvimos también trabajando y
respondiendo a los últimos cuatro meses
sino también por el tema de lakovic 19
recientemente se han identificado
algunos casos positivos en algunos
albergues que han influenciado por
supuesto a la manera en la que estamos
respondiendo lo que se hace es tomar
mayores precauciones lo que nosotros no
conocemos usualmente que es el uso de
máscara las distancias un testeo
permanente de las personas que están
entrando a los centros de evacuación
y emoción con aquellos que lo desean
voluntariamente también pueden adquirir
o tomarse su vacuna el gobierno las
autoridades también de san vicente y las
granadinas están facilitando la
vacunación de aquellas personas que lo
que quieran bueno pero usted cree que
todo esto el coi 19 el desplazamiento
las erupciones y además otras
enfermedades como el dengue podrían
generar una crisis humanitaria
si podría por supuesto estamos hablando
de lo que llamamos una situación
compleja en donde hay más de uno
más de una amenaza no es sólo las
consecuencias del volcán y las cenizas
sino también por supuesto la cob y 19 y
el dengue podría llegar a suceder una
crisis humanitaria exponencial pero en
este momento la situación es controlada
dentro de dentro del marco de lo que
podemos llamar una situación controlada
en especial patata bueno y además de eso
las autoridades han advertido que la
expulsión de humo y cenizas del volcán
podría afectar la calidad del aire no
sólo en esta sino en otras islas vecinas
como barbados y santa lucia hay algo que
se está haciendo para evitar un impacto
negativo en la salud y en el medio
ambiente
bueno en realidad demasiado que se puede
hacer para evitar un impacto en la salud
y el medio ambiente en la salud del
impacto se puede evitar que a través de
de tener las máscaras de los diferentes
tipos de máscara que se recomienda
constantemente a la población en la en
las comunidades que han sido afectadas y
después por supuesto vamos a tener que
estar trabajando con las consecuencias
de las herencias que están haciendo y
con las consecuencias de digamos en el
ámbito respiratorio y en el ámbito de la
subsistencia de las personas que van a
ver afectada su subsistencia porque las
acciones ya están por supuesto que
haciendo y arruinando las cosas ya
reinando la vida de los animales que se
usan para su propia alimentación y la
ecológica está por supuesto planificando
cómo va a ayudar a estas personas ha
llegado el momento pues agradecemos a
ariel que estén desde la jefatura de la
delegación para el caribe de habla
inglesa de la operación internación de
la cruz roja por estar en 5 minutos con
de france 24 y a usted gracias también
por estar con nosotros continúen con más
en las 24 punto com
[Música]